Wenn jemand anrief und ein
Crewmitglied etwas fragen wollte,
sagten wir: "Sie,
die sind jetzt hinter dem Mond."
Diese Besatzung ist nackt geflogen
auf dem Weg vom Mond zur Erde.
Dass der Mond
dann als Tankstelle dient
für zukünftige Raumfahrtmissionen.
Gibt es einen Grund,
warum man nicht zum Mond kann?
Wenn wir dorthin wollen,
sollten wir es versuchen.
In den 60er-Jahren spielte sich
ein Rennen im Weltraum ab.
Die Sowjetunion war den USA
dabei stets voraus:
erster Satellit im All,
erstes Tier mit Hündin Laika
und erster Mensch mit Juri Gagarin.
Aufgeschreckt
durch die russischen Erfolge
ergriff US-Präsident John F. Kennedy
1961 die Flucht nach vorne.
Der Startschuss
für das Rennen zum Mond.
Eine mutige Deadline,
denn bisher hatten die USA
ein paar Affen ins All geschickt.
Und einen Menschen -
allerdings nur gerade
für 15 Min. und 22 Sek.
Nur neun Jahre Zeit:
Die amerikanische Mondmission
glich einem Höllenritt
mit viel Risiko und enormen Kosten.
Bis zu 400'000 Leute
arbeiteten für das Apollo-Programm,
das nach heutigen Massstäben
über 100 Mrd. $ verschlang.
Das grösste Risiko
trugen die Astronauten,
ein paar von ihnen
starben während den Vorbereitungen.
Fast alle waren sie Militärpiloten.
Meist wilde Typen, die fliegen
konnten und Gefahren nicht scheuten.
Zwölf Astronauten landeten
schliesslich auf dem Mond.
Zehn von ihnen hat Lukas Viglietti
persönlich getroffen.
Der Westschweizer hat jüngst ein Buch
über die Moonwalker veröffentlicht.
Lukas Viglietti
war ein kleiner Junge,
als er den ersten Astronauten
live sah:
James Irwin,
der achte Mensch auf dem Mond.
Er war lustig,
er war nicht so gross,
er war nicht so muskulös,
er war sogar scheu.
Das hat mich sehr inspiriert
und ich habe mir gesagt:
"Er sieht fast gleich aus
wie wir alle."
"Vielleicht kann ich auch
an meine eigenen Träume glauben."
Viglietti wurde zwar nicht Astronaut,
aber immerhin Linienpilot.
Er nutzte
seine beruflichen USA-Reisen,
um die Moonwalker zu treffen.
Ein paar von ihnen
wurden seine Freunde.
Viglietti kennt die menschliche Seite
der Astronauten.
Sie waren keine Kinder
von Traurigkeit.
Denn um sich auf einer riesigen
Rakete zum Mond schiessen zu lassen,
dafür brauchte es keine Bürogummis,
sondern Space Cowboys.
Sie haben wirklich
das Leben genossen.
Sie hatten schöne Wagen,
einige fuhren Corvettes.
Sie haben sich nicht immer
an die Verkehrsregeln gehalten,
sie sind überall Risiken
eingegangen, auch auf der Strasse.
Sie waren auch sehr wild,
wie gesagt.
Einig hatten Affären.
Damals hat das
überhaupt nicht gepasst.
Die Kommunikationsabteilung der NASA
versuchte,
diese Menschen
als Superhelden zu verkaufen,
als perfekte Familienväter
und beste Amerikaner,
die man sich vorstellen kann.
In Realität waren sie einfach
Menschen mit Schwächen und Stärken.
Für die Kommunikationsabteilung
war das damals problematisch.
Gute PR war wichtig,
schliesslich wurden hier
Unmengen von Steuergeldern
sprichwörtlich verbrannt.
Die Space Cowboys im Zaum zu halten
war schwierig -
besonders Eugene Cernan.
Einmal stürzte er
mit dem Helikopter ab,
weil er Bikini-Girls am Strand
beeindrucken wollte.
Und es gibt noch
eine weitere Anekdote mit Cernan:
Einen Tag vor seinem Flug zum Mond
wurde er in der Nacht
von der Polizei aufgehalten,
weil er zu schnell gefahren war.
Die Polizisten fragten ihn mehrmals,
wer er sei und was er hier mache.
Doch er hatte sich geweigert,
zu sagen, wer er ist,
weil er vor den Konsequenzen
Angst hatte.
Plötzlich kam ein Ingenieur
von der NASA vorbei,
ein Kollege aus Deutschland.
Er ging zum Polizisten und sagte:
"Bitte, bitte,
lassen Sie diesen Mann frei,
denn er fliegt morgen zum Mond."
Da hatten die Polizisten gelacht
und leicht genervt gesagt:
"Okay, geh zu deinem Mond."
Mit jeder ihrer Apollo-Missionen
tastete sich die NASA
näher an ihr grosses Ziel heran.
Das Mondfieber steckte nach und nach
die ganze Welt an.
Auch die Schweiz.
Ein paar Solothurner Teenager
gründeten die TASA -
das Team Apollo Switzerland America.
Sie planten ihre ganz eigene Mission.
Schön, dass du da bist!
50 Jahre später sind die Männer
der TASA immer noch Freunde.
Im solothurnischen Gretzenbach
treffen sie sich
bei Kommandant Klemens Schenker.
Die Mitglieder der TASA sind so was
wie die Schweizer Apollo-Astronauten,
verbrachten doch drei von ihnen
zwei Wochen in einer Raumkapsel.
Schau mal!
- Echt!
Das Abenteuer der TASA
begann im Herbst 1968.
Fasziniert von den Berichten
über das Apollo-Programm
fassten sie den Entschluss,
selber eine Kapsel zu bauen.
Für mich war es klar:
Das ist ein Projekt,
das lassen wir nicht mehr los.
Jedes Wochenende
zimmerten die Jungs an ihrer Kapsel.
Oft bis tief in die Nacht hinein.
Sie wollten möglichst nahe
am Original der NASA bleiben.
Wenn wir etwas machen,
dann so echt wie möglich.
Es soll keine Kartonschachtel sein,
etwas bösartig gesagt,
sondern es soll Hand und Fuss haben.
Sie verbauten über 100 Schalter.
Und jeder dieser Schalter
hatte eine Funktion.
Sagenhafte 3,5 km Kabel
verlegten die Teenager.
Neben der Kapsel
bauten sie auch
ein passendes Kontrollzentrum
für den Boden - die Ground Control.
Während die Solothurner
an ihrer Kapsel bastelten,
galt es im Sommer 69 ernst
für die NASA.
Neil Armstrong und Buzz Aldrin
waren dazu bestimmt,
die ersten Menschen auf dem Mond
zu werden.
Es war die Mission Apollo 11.
Der dreitägige Flug
verlief problemlos.
Doch beim Anflug auf den Mond
mit der Landefähre Eagle
tauchten technische Probleme auf.
Armstrong musste
ein zusätzliches Manöver fliegen
auf der Suche
nach einem geeigneten Landeplatz.
Das verbrauchte mehr Treibstoff.
Die Mission Control in Houston
hatte Angst,
man hätte zu wenig Kerosin an Bord.
Doch der Treibstoff reichte.
Am Schluss, als sie landeten,
war für nicht mal mehr 20 Sek.
Treibstoff an Bord.
Das war sehr, sehr knapp.
Aber sie haben es geschafft.
21. Juli 1969 - kurz vor 4 Uhr
morgens Schweizer Zeit -
der grosse Moment:
die ersten Menschen auf dem Mond!
Die Freude war riesig:
nicht nur bei den Amerikanern,
sondern auch in Gretzenbach.
Ich ging raus und schaute zum Mond:
"Da oben sind nun zwei!"
Das geht einem
fast nicht in den Kopf.
Eine Frau hat mir erzählt,
sie habe die Mondlandung
mit dem Feldstecher gesehen.
Aber es war so: Sie war zu Hause,
hatte aber keinen Fernseher.
Der Nachbar aber schon,
und sie schaute
durchs offene Fenster.
Ah!
900'000 Schweizer verfolgten
die Mondlandung live am Fernseher.
Die Presse war sich einig:
Armstrong und Aldrin vollbrachten
das Abenteuer des Jahrhunderts.
Die Mondlandung
war ein globales Ereignis,
das die Welt
für einen kurzen Moment einte.
Und die USA
in die Leaderrolle katapultierte,
was Fortschritt und Entdeckungsgeist
anging.
Die Mission Apollo 11
dauerte acht Tage,
bis die Kapsel im Pazifik landete.
Die TASA-Kapsel in Gretzenbach dage-
gen wartete noch auf ihren Einsatz.
Der Bau hatte viel länger gedauert,
als je gedacht: 2 Jahre.
Was sollte man nun tun
mit diesem kleinen Meisterwerk?
Erstes Ziel war,
eine Kapsel zu bauen.
Als sie langsam fertig wurde,
war das Ziel ...
... 14 Tage darin zu verbringen.
Wie bei einer Apollo-Besatzung:
drei nebeneinander.
Ein Kommandant in der Mitte,
ein Bordarzt links
und ein Bordingenieur rechts.
Unter Anteilnahme des ganzen Dorfes
stiegen im Juli 1970
drei Mitglieder des Teams Apollo
Switzerland America in die Kapsel.
Die Luke
wurde für zwei Wochen plombiert.
Der Rest der Crew
übernahm die Bodenkontrolle,
welche im Nachbarhaus
installiert war.
Der Dorf-Elektriker
stellte sogar eine Überwachungskamera
zur Verfügung.
Die Hauptaufgabe war, dafür zu
sorgen, das alles funktioniert,
dass kein elektrischer Brand
oder so ausbricht.
Das war die Hauptaufgabe.
Darum arbeiteten wir in Schichten:
Man war 4 Std. am Kommandopult.
Dann war man 4 Std. als Reserve
dort. Dann konnte man schlafen.
In der Nacht
lief schon nicht so viel.
Man war froh, wenn die Polizei-
streife ab und zu zu Besuch kam.
Tagsüber hatte es aber immer Leute.
Es kamen immer Leute.
Wir hatten Checklisten, vor dem
Schlafen, am Morgen zum Aufstarten.
Das ging man immer gemeinsam durch
und überprüfte alles.
Wir haben einander
ein paar Mal Blut genommen.
Das wäre aber nicht nötig gewesen.
Wir machten das, damit der
Bordarzt eine gute Aufgabe hatte.
Blutdruck, Puls, Körpertemperatur -
alles wurde gemessen
und genau protokolliert.
Das Essen war eine Mischung
aus importiertem Astronauten-Food
und gutschweizerischen Produkten -
die irgendwann ja auch wieder
ausgeschieden werden mussten ...
Wir nahmen einen Camping-Klappstuhl
und stülpten einen Plastiksack
darüber.
Man sass auf den Stuhl,
verrichtete sein Geschäft,
dann drehte man den Plastiksack
sofort zu, verschloss ihn
und liess ihn
durchs Tunnel ins Freie fallen.
Wir holten es dann, wogen es,
massen die Flüssigkeit,
trugen alles schön ein
und entsorgten es.
Alles sollte
so echt wie möglich sein.
Auch die Kommunikation
mit der Ground Control.
Die Verbindung war immer da.
Aber wir simulierten ja
einen Mondflug,
und wenn ein Raumschiff
hinter dem Mond verschwindet,
ist es im Funkschatten.
Eine Mondumkreisung
dauert etwa 2 Std.,
und etwa 45 Min., wenn ich es
recht im Kopf habe, ist Funkstille.
Die rechneten wir aus
und hielten sie ein.
Auch tagsüber.
Wenn jemand anrief und ein
Crewmitglied etwas fragen wollte,
sagten wir: "Sie,
die sind jetzt hinter dem Mond."
Mit der gelungenen Mondlandung
hatte die USA das Moon Race gewonnen.
Fünf weitere Male
landeten die Amerikaner auf dem Mond.
Es gab keine Todesopfer, obwohl
die NASA im Vorfeld damit rechnete.
Abgesehen
von einem abgebrochenen Flug
waren die Apollo-Missionen
ein voller Erfolg.
Ganz ohne Stolpern
ging es dann aber doch nicht.
Für die letzten drei Missionen
schickte die NASA
einen Rover hoch zum Mond.
Die wilden Jungs der NASA
erlaubten sich trotz der
lebensbedrohlichen Umwelt des Mondes
ab und an ein kleines Spässchen.
So mit den allgegenwärtigen
Checklisten,
die die Astronauten
am Handgelenk trugen.
Bei der zweiten Mondlandung
entdeckten die Moonwalker
plötzlich eingeklebte Playmates
in ihren Checklisten -
ein Streich der Ersatzcrew.
Beim Rückflug derselben Besatzung
war nackte Haut erneut ein Thema.
Während der Mission von Apollo 12
waren die zwei Mondspazierer, die
in die Kommandokapsel zurückkamen,
ganz schmutzig.
Sie haben sich entschieden,
sich komplett auszuziehen,
die schmutzigen Kleider
zu verstauen.
Es ist erstaunlich, aber wahr,
wenn man das bedenkt:
Diese Besatzung ist nackt
vom Mond zur Erde zurückgeflogen.
Rund um die TASA-Mission stieg das
öffentliche Interesse mehr und mehr.
In ein konisches Gartenhäuschen -
Weltraumkapsel nachgebildet -
haben sich drei junge Menschen
seit einer Woche eingeschlossen.
Aus Begeisterung für die Mondfahrt
wollen sie
die Sensationen der Astronauten
eine Woche nachempfinden.
Was halten Gleichaltrige davon?
Ich finde es Stumpfsinn,
da zwei Wochen drinzusitzen.
Man könnte in dieser Zeit
Gescheiteres machen.
Lesen wäre besser in dieser Zeit.
Und im Sommer gibt's Besseres,
als da drin zu hocken.
Das war im Grunde
auch eine gute Lehre:
zu spüren, dass nicht alle
gut fanden, was wir machten.
Es gab auch Kritik, v.a. während des
Versuchs, als er eben publik wurde.
Damit umzugehen, einerseits für
die Leute, die in der Kapsel waren -
die standen ja
unter besonderem Stress.
Wenn einer sagt, die hätten besser
ein Gartenhäuschen gebaut,
geriet der Commander
natürlich fast ausser Rand und Band.
Was hat er gesagt? "Gartenhäuschen"?
Ihre Mission
wurde von manchen zwar belächelt,
doch die TASA-Astronauten
hielten durch.
Und sie blieben länger
in einer Kapsel
als je irgendein
amerikanischer Astronaut.
Als die zwei Wochen vorüber waren,
warteten 2'000 Leute
auf den Ausstieg der Raumfahrer.
Viel Presse war da,
die Blasmusik spielte und Ehrendamen
nahmen die Teenager in Empfang.
Mir war das eher peinlich.
Ich war so was nicht gewohnt.
Es war einerseits eine grosse
innere Freude und Zufriedenheit,
wie bei allen,
die da mitgemacht haben.
Aber dann einen Moment lang
so ausgestellt sein -
da habe ich mich nicht immer
so wohl gefühlt, muss ich sagen.
Zwei Jahre nach der TASA-Mission
endete auch das Mond-Abenteuer
der NASA.
1972 verliess der letzte Mensch
den Mond: Eugene Cernan.
Wir erinnern uns:
Der Mann, der einst in einer
Verkehrskontrolle hängenblieb.
Vier wilde Jahre waren vorbei.
Und plötzlich interessierte sich
kaum mehr jemand für den Mond.
Jahrzehntelang.
Je ruhiger es um den Mond wurde,
umso lauter wurden Stimmen,
die behaupteten, die Mondlandung
habe gar nie stattgefunden.
Wen trafen solche Theorien
am stärksten?
Es waren die Moonwalker selbst.
Die Apollo-Astronauten
leiden immer noch,
wenn Leute immer und immer wieder
an ihrer Geschichte zweifeln.
Das schmerzt sehr.
Wenn ich persönlich mit Astronauten
bin und solche Leute treffe,
dann versuche ich sofort zu ant-
worten, den Astronaut zu schützen.
Lukas Viglietti
war jedoch nicht dabei,
als 2002 einer dieser Verschwörungs-
theoretiker auf Buzz Aldrin traf
und ihn als Lügner und Dieb
bezeichnete.
In Amerika gibt es einen Jour-
nalisten, der ist ziemlich giftig:
Bart Sibrel.
Er ging zu fast allen Mondspazierern
und wollte sie
vor laufender Kamera zwingen,
auf die Bibel zu schwören, dass
sie wirklich auf dem Mond waren.
Mit der Hand auf der Bibel.
Bei gewissen Leuten
war das keine gute Erfahrung.
Buzz Aldrin hat ihm sogar
einen Faustschlag verpasst.
Aldrin hatte auch mit 72 Jahren
noch ordentlich Punch.
Und der Punch ist auch wieder
in der Mondfahrt zurück.
Nationen aber auch private Firmen
starten zum Moon Race 2.0.
Das sind z.B. die Chinesen.
Sie landeten Anfang 2019
auf der Rückseite des Mondes,
als erste Nation der Welt.
China plant auch bemannte Missionen.
Ein Taikonaut auf dem Mond?
Das schreckt die Amerikaner auf.
Vizepräsident Mike Pence fürchtet
um die Vorherrschaft im Weltraum.
Schon 2024 wollen die USA
also wieder auf den Mond.
Ein sehr sportlicher Zeitplan.
Denn die NASA
hat weder einen Mondlander
noch eine funktionierende Rakete,
sondern nur hübsche Animationen.
Ihr Space Launch System
ist um Jahre verzögert.
Die Nächsten auf dem Mond werden
voraussichtlich die Inder sein.
Läuft alles nach Plan,
landen sie im September 2019
mit einer Sonde auf dem Mond.
Damit wären sie die vierte Nation
auf dem Erdtrabanten.
Und da sind auch noch die Russen.
Die haben funktionierende Raketen
und den Plan, dass sie mittelfristig
jedes Jahr Kosmonauten
auf den Mond bringen wollen.
Etwas ist beim neuen Mondrennen
fundamental anders als früher:
Neben Nationen
sind auch private Firmen dabei.
Sie sind es,
die am meisten Schub bringen.
Allen voran Elon Musk,
der Rockstar unter den Raketenbauern.
Er und seine Fima SpaceX
lieben den grossen Auftritt.
Zu PR-Zwecken schiessen sie auch mal
einen Tesla ins All.
Jeff Bezos -
der reichste Mann der Welt -
ist auch mit von der Partie
beim Mondrennen.
Wow!
Mit seinem Raketenunternehmen
Blue Origin
fokussiert er bislang v.a.
auf den Transport von Gütern ins All.
In Europa schliesslich
ist die französische Ariane Group
der grosse Player.
Mit ihrer neuen Rakete Ariane 6
will sie bald Richtung Mond abheben.
Mit an Bord: Ein Mondlander
der deutschen Firma PT Scientists.
PT Scientists ist ein junges, aber
ambitioniertes New-Space-Unternehmen
mit 70 Mitarbeitern
und Sitz in Berlin.
Mit zum Mond fliegen
soll auch dieser knuffige Rover.
Der Schweizer Pius Durrer
ist dafür verantwortlich,
dass der Rover auf dem Mond
weder überhitzt noch gefriert.
PT Scientists planen für 2021
einen globalen Event unter dem Label
"Mission to the moon".
Sie machen sich dabei auf die Suche
nach einem Überbleibsel
des alten Mondrennens.
"Mission to the moon"
ist die Absicht,
mit unserem Landesystem zurückzu-
fliegen zur Apollo-17-Landingsite.
Mit der Apollo 17 waren die
Amerikaner letztmals auf dem Mond.
Wir werden
in der Nähe der Apollo 17 landen.
Wir werden zwei Audi lunar quattro
aussetzen,
das sind Rover, die wir unter
Mithilfe von Audi entwickelt haben.
Mit diesen beiden Rovern
werden wir zur Landingsite
der Amerikaner zurückfahren
und schauen,
was dort übrig geblieben ist.
Dass zwei Rover unterwegs sind,
hat seinen Grund.
So kann der eine Rover
den anderen filmen,
was interessantere Bilder gibt.
Denn die Welt soll teilhaben
an der Mission und miterleben,
was von der letzten aller
Mondexpeditionen noch zu sehen ist.
Man wird dort
verschiedene Experimente finden,
die die Amerikaner
zurückgelassen haben.
Man wird den unteren Bereich
des Landemoduls und die Fahne sehen.
Vermutlich ist sie eher weiss
wegen der Strahlung.
Man wird das Rover-Modul sehen,
also das Auto, das die Amerikaner
damals gefahren sind.
Ist dieses Rover-Vehikel inzwischen
zerfallen oder steht es noch?
Wurde es von einem Meteoriten
getroffen oder nicht?
Auf solche Fragen
erhoffen wir uns Antworten.
Der Besuch einer alten
Apollo-Landestelle ist clever:
So lockt man auch
die Mondlandungsskeptiker
und Verschwörungstheoretiker an.
Ziel dieser Mission ist auch,
dass man live sehen kann,
wie diese Rover auf dem Mond fahren.
Man möchte einen Apollo-Moment
für die jetzige Generation schaffen.
Das Livesignal
von "Mission to the moon"
wird weltweit vertrieben
von Red Bull Media House.
Und die wissen spätestens
seit dem Stratossprung aus 40'000 m,
wie weltweites Content-Marketing
erfolgreich umgesetzt wird.
Die wissen,
wie man grosse Sachen aufzieht.
Es ist auch für uns sehr spannend,
wie man das erreichen kann.
Ich werde sicher darauf achten,
was Red Bull Media House
anders macht als andere.
Darauf bin ich sehr gespannt.
Es ist eine grosse Wette,
die PT Scientists hier eingeht.
Sie könnten als Loser dastehen.
Wenn die Mission aber gelingt,
haben sie
den perfekten globalen Werbespot.
Man kann zeigen,
dass man in der Lage ist,
zum Mond zu fliegen
und dort zu landen.
Man kann zeigen, dass man in der
Lage ist, mit Rovern zu operieren.
Das ganze Drumherum,
die Technologie, die wir entwickeln,
brauchen wir später, um
weitere Missionen zu gewährleisten.
Dadurch können wir als Firma
weiter bestehen.
Wir wollen das nicht nur einmal tun
und einen tollen Moment erleben,
sondern wir wollen das,
was wir dafür bauen und entwickeln,
für künftige Mondmissionen
weiterverwenden
und Kunden zur Verfügung stellen.
Businessleute und Politiker -
alle wollen sie wieder auf den Mond.
Aber wofür eigentlich?
Warum ist der Mond
plötzlich wieder so interessant?
1972, mit dem Apollo-Programm,
war es v.a. Neugierde,
die die Menschen
auf den Mond getrieben hat.
Und es war auch der Wettbewerb
zwischen den USA und Russland.
Dass wir jetzt wieder auf den Mond
gehen, hat ein längerfristiges Ziel:
Der Mond soll als Zwischenstation
dienen, um weiter ins All zu gehen.
Die Maschinenbauingenieurin
Anna Kiener befasst sich damit,
wie der Mensch
auf dem Mond leben könnte.
Als Mitarbeiterin
des Swiss Space Centers
betreut sie ein internationales
Studentenprojekt zu diesem Thema.
Und sie baut mit anderen Studenten
Raketen für einen Wettkampf
in den USA.
Letztes Jahr mit einem unguten Ende
für die Rakete Tell.
Das ist Tell.
Leider nicht die Tell,
die in den USA gestartet ist.
Ich war sehr nervös, ich durfte
sogar den Startknopf drücken.
Sie ist leider
schon nach 1,4 Sek. explodiert.
Hier sehen wir einige Überreste
dieser Rakete.
Das war einmal ein Finnemodul.
Es war schon sehr hart.
Wir hatten ein Jahr lang
daran gearbeitet
und sind voller Motivation
dorthin gegangen.
Aber so schnell geht es halt
in der Raumfahrttechnik -
wenn etwas schiefgeht,
ist die ganze Mission vorbei.
Der Fehler für den Absturz
lag nicht bei den Studenten,
der eingekaufte Treibsatz war defekt.
Raketen starten zu lassen war
schon immer eine risikoreiche Sache.
Daran hat sich auch
50 Jahre nach Apollo 11
grundsätzlich nichts geändert.
Auch Elon Musk
musste mit seinen SpaceX-Raketen
zahlreiche Rückschläge
in Kauf nehmen.
Auf YouTube zelebriert er seine
Crashes und Abstürze richtiggehend.
Ein solches Video der NASA -
undenkbar.
Schliesslich schaffte es SpaceX
Raketen zu bauen,
die wieder landen können.
Dank dieser wiederverwertbaren
Raketen sanken die Preise.
Ein Launch bei SpaceX
kostet im Schnitt
aber immer noch 50 Mio. $.
PT Scientists rechnet mit rund
100 Mio. Euro für ihre Mondmission.
Geld verdienen wollen sie, indem sie
Pakete auf den Mond bringen,
sog. Payloads.
Unter Payload kann man sich
alles mögliche vorstellen,
meistens sind es aber
relativ kleine Sachen
wie Experimente
oder Technologietests.
Es kann auch ein Kunstprojekt sein.
Wenn ein Künstler sein Kunstprojekt
auf den Mond bringen will,
kann es rein theoretisch
mit uns mitfliegen.
Aktuell liegt der Kilogrammpreis
bei ca. 1 Mio.
Mit bis zu 300 kg Payloads könnte
sich das Ganze durchaus rechnen.
Das Konzept von PT Scientists
geht noch weiter.
Die Lander selber
bleiben auf dem Mond
und bauen ein Kommunikationsnetz auf,
das von den Kunden
genutzt werden kann.
Wir sind nicht einfach nur
der Paketlieferant zum Mond,
sondern ein Paketlieferant,
der zudem hilft,
das Paket auszupacken, korrekt
zu betreiben, zusammenzubauen
oder was immer man
dort oben machen will.
Die Lösung
muss weitergedacht werden.
Doch da gibt es noch jemanden,
der gerne Pakete
zum Mond liefern möchte.
Amazon-Chef Jeff Bezos
hat jüngst auch einen Mondlander
vorgestellt.
Der Lander Blue Moon ist so gross,
dass er auch für den Transport
von Menschen genutzt werden könnte.
Bezos hofft
auf einen Auftrag der NASA
aber dann wäre man ja erst wieder so
weit wie vor 50 Jahren schon mal.
Doch eigentlich ist das Ziel,
auf dem Mond zu bleiben -
und das wird nicht einfach.
Die Bedingungen auf dem Mond
sind sehr harsch.
Man muss lernen, wie man dort
trotzdem irgendwie leben kann.
Der Mond ist überhaupt nicht
wie die Erde.
Es ist nicht freundlich
gegenüber Leben.
Es gibt keine Atmosphäre.
Es landen ständig Meteoriten
auf der Oberfläche.
Das Gefährlichste
sind die Strahlungen.
Dagegen muss man sich
irgendwie schützen.
Ein erster Schritt wäre sicher,
Erkundungsroboter hochzuschicken
und alles über die Bedingungen
auf dem Mond zu lernen.
Danach könnten diese Roboter
einen Schutz für die Menschen bauen,
der vor Strahlungen
oder Meteoriten schützt.
Dann könnte man
Menschen hochschicken,
die direkt in die
geschützte Umgebung gehen könnten.
An einem solchen Roboter
tüfteln ETH-Studenten.
Bald testen sie im Rahmen
des internationalen Igluna-Projektes
die Maschine
im Gletschereis über Zermatt.
Dort werden auch
weitere Konzepte vorgestellt,
wie sich Studenten ein Leben
auf dem Mond vorstellen könnten.
Häuser in Lavakanälen
sind geschützt vor Strahlung,
Meteoriten und
Temperaturschwankungen.
Ein Pflanzenroboter recycelt
die Fäkalien der Astronauten
und züchtet automatisch Pflanzen
als Nahrung.
Auch der physischen und psychischen
Gesundheit der Mondbewohner
soll Sorge getragen werden werden.
Trainiert und entspannt
wird in lunaren Fitnessstudios.
Über ein spezielles Interface
agieren die Menschen mit Pflanzen
und bauen so
Beziehungen mit ihnen auf.
So sollen die Pflanzen
zu einem Haustierersatz werden.
Schaut man die jetzige Situation an,
gibt es immer mehr Menschen.
Leider sind Ressourcen und Platz
auf der Erde endlich.
Wenn wir eine interplanetare Spezies
werden könnten,
könnten wir dem etwas
entgegenhalten. Aber nicht nur das:
Indem wir das machen,
auf den Mond gehen und noch weiter,
entstehen neue Technologien, die uns
eine neue Zukunft ermöglichen,
die wir uns heute
nicht vorstellen können.
Die Europäische Weltraumorganisation
ESA
denkt schon
über ein Moon Village nach.
Als Testlabor, wie der Mensch
abseits der Erde überleben könnte.
Entscheidend dafür ist,
dass man auf dem Mond
Wasser, Sauerstoff und Treibstoff
gewinnen kann.
Wenn wir auf dem Mond
eine permanente Basis haben,
würde das bedeuten,
dass wir einen Zwischenstopp,
eine Tank- und Raststelle hätten,
um weiter ins Weltall zu gehen.
Vorteil: Die Gravitationskraft
ist nur ein Sechstel
im Vergleich zur Erde.
Es braucht auf dem Mond viel weniger
Treibstoff als auf der Erde.
Oder man könnte auch grössere Cargos
oder Raketen ins Weltall launchen.
Und dann soll es Richtung Mars gehen.
So stellt sich das auch Elon Musk
und seine Firma SpaceX vor.
Hunderttausende
sollen dereinst auf dem Mars leben.
Eine nicht weniger abgespacete Vision
hat Jeff Bezos.
Er schlägt vor, kilometerlange Röhren
im Weltraum zu bauen.
Durch Rotation
wird künstliche Schwerkraft erzeugt.
Die Temperatur ist immer perfekt,
es regnet nie
und die Welten erschafft man sich
nach seinen Vorstellungen.
Allerdings: Bevor man die Luzerner
Kapellbrücke im Weltall nachbaut,
gäbe es vielleicht auch
eine naheliegendere Lösung.
Die wichtigste Lektion
der Raumfahrt ist, zu sagen:
Wir sind 8 Mrd. Astronauten
auf dem grössten und perfektesten
Raumschiff namens Erde.
Und jetzt, in diesem Moment,
in welchem wir reden,
fliegen wir durch das Weltall -
mit Tausenden Kilometern pro Stunde.
Und das ist doch erstaunlich.
Deshalb sollten wir uns
unseren Bedingungen bewusst sein,
und lernen, friedlicher miteinander
auf diesem Planeten zu leben
und auf unser Raumschiff zu achten.